the jurgen experience
in la you can't do anything i mean la's
the one place in the whole country where
you can't
open a beauty salon you can't these all
these hairdressers and barber shops are
[ __ ]
right they've been closed for six months
you see that nancy pelosi [ __ ]
did you see that that did how [ __ ]
crazy is that lady
she she without a mat without wearing a
mask i mean you want to talk about a
hypocrite
the the [ __ ] all the beauty salons
are locked down she went into the beauty
salon
with no mask wandering around got a
blowout
when no one else could even go to the
beauty salon they caught her
on security camera they uploaded it and
you know what she said
it's a setup she she said it was a setup
right like they set her up
like you know the [ __ ] i don't even
have any hair
right and i know you can't go to a
beauty salon
i mean it doesn't apply to you joe
literally literally doesn't apply to me
at all and i know the [ __ ] rules
she's the speaker of the house
you're telling me you don't know the
rules in your district in san francisco
you don't know the rules of course you
know the rules of course you do that's
so
slippery that lady handed trump a giant
gift oh yeah it was almost like when uh
when uh hillary called the supporters a
black basket of deplorables i'm like you
just
handed a man that had a baton a bat to
hit you with
and not a regular one stupid ones
yeah the minute i heard that i was like
oh god yeah
i thought you're supposed to be smart
she's not smart she's just a politician
she's just greasy they've just been
doing it long enough so they know the
the
moves to do and the right steps it's
like yeah
they're all gross it's just there's no
getting around it
you can't you can't survive in that
business if you're if you're not gross
right you just that's how you get there
that's how you stay there
and they they they feed off of the fact
that they have control
they feed off of the fact they have
power over other people they have more
power than anyone else and that's
one of the reasons why she would do
something like that you tell me she
can't get someone to come to her house
and wear a mask and give her a blowout
she's worth a hundred million
dollars of course she can do that right
but she's like
i'm gonna walk right in there and
they're gonna do it for me
i'm not gonna wear a mask right i've
never washed my own hair
she's gonna stroll right in there like
she owns the joint it's just
like when you see politicians being
hypocritical like that lady in
chicago the mayor of chicago she's like
you know
talking up these people in these
peaceful protests and
everything's fine but then they tried
protesting on her block she set up
[ __ ] armed guards
she said made a mandate you can't i'm
not a mandate
she just said you can't protest on her
street right
i have a right to protect my own safety
like [ __ ] that's what everybody's
trying to do
right that's what we're in here that's
what we're doing that's what we're doing
but that's what people feel when they
get into a position of power that's the
problem with power
that's the problem with whether it's
garcetti or newsom or anybody dictating
any of these rules
when someone gets into a position of
power it's [ __ ] intoxicating
the ability to tell people you can't
work right shut it down
you know start it up shut it down like
it's intoxicating
and once you have some power boy it's
very difficult to give that power up
i i anticipate that even if they figure
out a real cure
for coronavirus i anticipate lockdowns
now for flu
i think there's going to be lockdowns
for all sorts of diseases that kill a
certain amount of people
yeah you could you could you might be
might be wrong
but you could see it happening you could
see it happening because they've set a
precedent for them
having the ability to dictate whether or
not people work and whether or not
people are allowed to move freely and do
whatever they want
because that's what happens when people
have power it's a [ __ ] dangerous
intoxicant
well i believe you're right about that
uh that it's a
it's a it's
dizzying uh how sexy power is
and how sexy you feel when you have it
and uh
and that but i don't think you know
i i think we find a i think we find a
vaccine we move on
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love